We got some animals.
And we exposed them
to green light.
And then we tested them.
And we saw that they developed
better capacity to handle
uncomfortable stimulus.
The more we optimized the
system, the more potent,
if you will, the effect
of the green light became.
And I thought, since this is
very noninvasive, we did not
see any side-effects
on the animals,
what's holding us from
trying it on humans?
I have fibromyalgia
very severely.
And I've had that for 20
years, terrible, terrible, nine
or 10 pain.
And this brought it
down quite a bit.
The study is 10 weeks long.
We provide them
with a green light.
And at the end of
the study, I ask
them to return the light to
us along with some surveys
to document their pain, how
their pain is improving over
the 10 weeks period.
So we brought the lights home.
And my husband built
this frame for it.
And for 10 weeks, I did this,
about three feet away from you,
in a darkened room, and do it
for an hour or two every night.
After two days, I could
tell that my pain was less.
And I just couldn't believe it.
You don't expect things to work.
But it worked.
She became happier,
more interactive.
She was doing more stuff
with her family and friends.
And when she returned
the light, she
was sad because she felt she's
going to lose all that effect.
So we just contacted her, and
we returned the light to her
and told her, just use it.
If it's that helpful,
go ahead and use it.
So she was very happy.
I still have pain.
But it's so different
than lying in bed
and crying with the pain.
It just made a huge difference
in how I felt about myself
and how I felt about life.
And I owe that to Dr.
Ibrahim and his lights.
I bring to Raj some
of the problems
we face in the pain clinic
with some of the really hard
to treat pain conditions.
And we tried to
come up with models
to see if there are better
ways to manage such pain,
or to at least understand
the nature of that pain.
And once we have
better understanding,
we might be able to
find a better management
to address that pain.
In this case, it's green light.
It's actually very safe.
So we see a path much faster.
You can imagine
eyeglasses, for example,
being designed that have
the same effect, that people
can wear.
So that's very important.
But at the same time, while
that progresses to humans,
it's very important for us to
understand how it's working.
And that's where we still
need to do studies in rodents.
We need to make sure that
the mechanisms we envision
are working to bring
about pain relief
are actually what's happening.
So one of the goals
we had in mind
when we started on this project
is define also something
in addition to being safe and
efficacious, to be affordable.
And thankfully, so far
anyway, light is still cheap.
Not if you want
designer eyeglasses.
Exactly.